if you want in this triangular Enclave
what would you like a rap about
Ireland are you yourself Irish no no why
did you know
what now
your boyfriend's Irish exactly he's not
here tonight oh
what aspect of Ireland would you like us
to focus on
music music Irish music fun great that's
a great suggestion are there any Irish
bands that you particularly enjoy your
boyfriend's an Irish musician the
imagination on display this is really
cool
you could have picked anything you just
like the guy that I kind of like but
also
Irish musicians lovely your boyfriend as
well let's come to um the kind of if
you're just at the back of the room I
want to give you guys an opportunity
what was that
colonization
I I can't see YouTube since you know
it's quite dim over there and I can't
like hear from your accent are you from
a country that was colonized foreign
[Applause]
you're welcome slash I'm sorry
may I inquire as to the the country
the US
okay cool yeah
I mean I'm sorry slash you're welcome
still holds
okay colonization of the US by the
British Irish musicians let's come to
the middle of the room from the side to
the side
Gothic Catholic churches thank you very
much cool just so you know Gothic is the
style of architecture not Catholic
churches that we're all black
[Music]
um
and are you thinking of God are you
thinking of Gothic or neogothic
no look what do you sit at home and oh
Wikipedia it's just uh
we'll figure it out okay colonization of
the state Irish musicians Gothic
Catholic churches let's come to the
middle Center and don't worry people
over here will come to you that's the
middle of the room
there were so so many
so ball soup the queen you said a [ __ ]
taxidermist
we found the crowd favorite
[Applause]
you have the final suggestion usually
I'd say make it the best but [ __ ]
taxidermist do [ __ ] good
double decker bus thank you for the
emphasis on that as well double decker
bus yeah
whoa that is what all British people
think Americans are alike when they're
in London whoa Buckingham Palace
card with a big head
so these are our topics Irish musician
colonization of the states Gothic
Catholic Church's [ __ ] Taxidermy if I
remember I'll throw in the queen in
matzo ball soup and a double decker bus
so my lovely band it's been it's been
I've not I've been away since
April right so I'm excited to to get
back together with you guys again yeah
we broke up we went on Hiatus so now
we're now we're back so let's uh my gosh
are you gonna break the speakers with
that
oh no I'm not that's not a criticism
Red's like oh I'm really sorry Chris
I'll change it for a less 8080 sounds
so beautiful isn't it nice why are you
doing this with your face you seem
apprehensive you're now spanning
yourself okay cool
we'll start it off you seem pertured but
how this might end put him on last year
rap about my friend he's a boy but not
here on my right I came out comedy
selling my girl tonight where's he from
his Skin's ever so pasty white I eat
potatoes never sees the daylight well if
I like it maybe just a little he plays I
presume the Irish fiddle or some type of
flute oh fiddle DT when I get quite
drunk he might fickle with me
potentially obviously my hand inspired
about the boyfriend from my land is he
Northern Irish or they're from the
Republic can he read sheet music and
instruct it like a conductor in the
Irish Orchestra it's just leprechauns
with ginger hair and they let from there
over here to this country moving back in
the day in the 1600s they're on the
Mayflower Pilgrim fathers from England
but they're like we'd rather go to nicer
climates with more sun let's set sail
across the sea and find a new one oh
America yeah we don't hate this oh hello
there's the Indians the native give them
the blanket take it Lots now we own this
because you're dead of smallpox I'm not
encouraging it obviously it was sad
colonization it really turned out bad
but let me talk about something that's
much much more pretty see over there in
the middle Century of Italy the Catholic
Church they're like we won't stop it
construct all the houses of worship in
the gothic style and if you let your
brain kind of are they used to have the
type of Gothic Arch the difference is
it's not curved it's got a little Point
that's hard to construct and that's my
point are you an architecture student
far more prudent no the Catholic church
it's led by the pope who did they have
Benedict
what's his favorite soup matzo balls
he's so Keen leader of the church would
never meet the queen she runs the CFE
the Church of England if they ever met
they would get into fisticuffs like yo
poppy your battle puts him up I put the
thumb with the half of a double decker
bus coming in I'll aim straight for your
head then I deck you twice double leave
your face red with the blood that's
bubbling from your nose you saw these
all right hook coming and then come the
corgis they're attacking you fighting
with their teeth the last thing you
won't believe what a sea walking to was
shot the action it concerned me I see a
guy there with his Taxidermy he's got a
dead Beaver Jerry starts ruffling the
hairs then he says I'm giving it to
stuffing what do you need that's really
yucky you're [ __ ] the dead Beaver oh
yucky
taxidermist that's a [ __ ] Pearl
[Applause]